hey what's up beautiful babies welcome
to another episode of get close
uh i hate to say this but i have
a family member on
david so
what a piece of [ __ ]
i am your host geo not a piece of [ __ ]
and i'm bart
why am i a piece of [ __ ] i don't know
anything about you the way you smell the
way you look the fact that we actually
came on time to your podcast exactly
it's ridiculous we were waiting here for
about five minutes you went away to make
your face better and it looks exactly
the same okay wow that's crazy that's
crazy no effort into i mean you actually
look you wore pants i'm proud of this
looks [ __ ] fresh yes it does
he doesn't even take it seriously you on
the other hand like did you even try
this is
a limited edition stand-up boys chimey
suit
that's pretty dope
i mean yeah but like not to wear shout
outs to the sandal boys for sending this
to me i forgot to shout you guys on
instagram someone do it on this podcast
yo appreciate you guys ahaha
you know [ __ ] you david okay you wake up
smelling like [ __ ]
because i sleep next to that guy no no
no
you just had to get you just had to get
the little blanket
okay you know what this is
this is about getting close you freaking
scum bucket oh i want to get close to
you even though i am really close to you
we've known each other for what
almost 10 years man
no no really we've known each other for
almost 10 years when was the uh san
diego asian film festival sadaf
i didn't go to that yeah i met them
first and then i conversed with you to
your body so angry
yes uh so when was that like two
thousand i really don't know but it's a
long time okay we'll just for the sake
of math we'll just say we've known each
other for eight years
you've married us
yeah you've met a little longer than
that i think maybe like 11 or something
like 10 or 11 now yeah close to it no
yeah nice so we've known each other for
over a decade yeah a little too long huh
yeah we look a little old i don't know
what you're talking about okay well we
look a little bit old yesterday i don't
know okay well anyway
uh you started off as an arch nemesis
still kind of are a little bit we didn't
really like each other too much
uh no we actually hit it off i want to
stay right off the bat yeah
we could uh she's not very good at
assessing her friendships but i'll just
say this right now she was okay yeah was
that you didn't really like me no you
were great i think all you guys were
great yeah you guys were all fantastic
no [ __ ] that's what i wanted to hear no
but uh so on this podcast we really just
want to connect with people that
we never have like these serious moments
we don't but we're gonna get serious
when she says connect i'm like how much
more can we connect here
before this podcast for the sake of this
podcast right of course let's connect
let's let's let's talk deep about our
feelings and see where we're at you i
don't even know i don't want to talk
about it
can you chime in a little bit no i'm
waiting for you to do your goddamn job i
know she's over here just scamping and
scared my squad i swear to squatting
skin it's quite a squatter okay so uh
yes we brought you on to this podcast
believe it or not which i know you're
gonna believe it because you know we
love you um is that we love you we're
inspired by you we're motivated by you
um we see what it is that you're doing
in the space in your space whether
that's you know specifically youtube or
like movies or even the food space even
the podcast space even the music space
bro what the [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
talented um and we highly respect
your art
and we love you and we want to get close
to you when it comes to that what do you
respect about me the most please let me
know i respect um honestly i respect the
fact that
you can walk around with that face
still love yourself
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
it's hard
every day no not all superheroes wear
capes
oh [ __ ] it's a lot no but really okay
for for y'all listening that are like
wait who's this david guy so this is
davidso uh started off on youtube uh
start off in the stand-up comedy world
back when he was like 16 actually back
in the day day right but uh this was
like i want to say your big break kind
of mm-hmm right
uh so yes he was a stand-up comedian was
doing it since he was 16 years old now
you're what 46. roughly about there give
or take about six or seven years okay
uh so you're like in your mid-thirties
um but i want to say like in your
earlier 20s
uh you you made this viral video blew up
and and that was kind of like that's
where i first saw you
um you were
kind of giving a rebuttal to someone
that was saying some dumb [ __ ] about the
asian community and it was such a good
[ __ ] funny video that i'm like yo who
is this guy uh so saw you there and then
from there you like it blossomed into
like you you started doing like short
skits and then you started doing
commentary and then you like had this
[ __ ] angel voice so you put out like
original music and i'm like the [ __ ]
wait what's going on you guys well my
hair my facial hair is coming in oh
which is kind of crazy
uh so you have uh original music that
you do you sing really well and then you
started putting out like slightly here
and there you would put out like
lifestyle vlogs and the editing on that
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] good i'm like this
dude's really [ __ ] talented maybe the
talented [ __ ] yeah and then so
he like on top of that he was like well
i really do like a lot of food and then
he starts cooking on his [ __ ] channel
and he starts breaking food down and
then like within the homie circle he's
like cooking us food and it's like
[ __ ] good food
like bro
you do everything and then you were like
okay well that's not enough so yeah um i
think i'm gonna put out like
a film
and you did just that you got awards at
sundance like
bro that's [ __ ] amazing
don't follow what i do though it's not a
very very smart life choice
uh it's not very stable
it doesn't matter but i think that's one
thing that i respect about you is that
you're a man of many talents and trust
me when i tell you that it's hard for me
to say this [ __ ] outside of my heart you
know what i mean like keeping this in my
heart because it's david and we just
have to have this rivalry you know what
i
mean
uh we both respect each other i know
you're gonna disagree
this is our relationship we have to talk
to about each other but
i do i respect the fact that like you're
you're good at so many things you're
like this creative genius and there's
nothing that really stops you from doing
what you want to do you're like
hey today i want to just [ __ ] go cook
some [ __ ] and film it and talk about it
and now like you guys do send foods
um where you guys go around different
places in you know the us and you're
breaking down food and talking about it
and i'm like yo that's sick and then
you're like
damn i can actually sing so yeah i want
to make my own music and you do that
[ __ ] and i think that's [ __ ] dope
like
who has the balls to do [ __ ] like that
somebody who doesn't know who they are
what do you mean i feel like you
are you have to be a confident person to
be like
i'm gonna do it anyway well how do you
function
how do you do things is this a trick
question no like how do you function
idiot
what do you mean
how do you navigate stuff that you want
to do um
i don't know if i do as much as you do i
don't know if i have the confidence in
the stuff that i want to do as much as
you do to get out there and like show
your [ __ ] to the world but you're a
lot but your guy's life is a lot more
stable than mine though so there's like
a give and take right it's like if you
if you choose this route which is very
selfish it's inherently selfish for you
it has to be where you want to pursue
the things that you want to do despite
the fact that there's a lot of stuff
that are there's a lot of repercussions
to the things that i do right so if you
if you're a highly opinionated person
there's a lot of people who don't want
to work with you right but then if you
have to cater to yourself to what
everybody else wants then you can't
express yourself the way that you want
to you end up in my personal opinion
being very unhappy because you have to
always do what everybody else wants
right but then there's like this weird
moment too i feel like a lot of kids are
going to figure this out you're going to
hit this age where you're going to be
like i only have x amount of time on
this earth i have catered my whole life
doing what everybody else told me i
should do well guess what with these 40
or 50 years i have left of like quality
life what am i going to do with it when
did you figure that out because like i
feel like the thing that i admire the
most about you probably since day one
back at sadaf which is san diego asian
american film festival
was that you've always been
unapologetically you yes to the point
where when me and jose do shows i always
wanted to wear basketball shorts and
sandals i saw my show no she said no
this guy so me and joe are like fine we
gotta wear real clothes well what's the
most presentable thing maybe look like a
mechanic
so we wore dickies outfits and that was
like our show clothes right but i gotta
wear my oscar clothes man
but then when i first saw you i'm like
that's what i want to wear literally
that night he was like he's like why are
you making me wear this look david's
wearing this and i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] about david this is a film festival
right a place where people go and
present their best work to get judged
we're panelists we're supposed to be
authorities and when we're there
speaking this whole time just looking
over that dave like [ __ ]
god damn and so since day one i've been
that's the thing i admire about you and
then i think from there all the way to
what you do now music film food
everything it's literally what you want
how you want to do it and you just do it
and you pursue it and i hear that you're
like you know there's it comes a time
where you're like i only have limited
time so i better make use of that time
when did all of that click because it
clicked like even 10 years before yeah
um i i think that happened just because
of like i think a lot of asian kids when
you go to college they uh they have this
moment where they they live their whole
life from what their parents told them
to do right and i think i fought with my
parents and i had that [ __ ] you moment
with my parents very early early on as
early as like high school because i was
trying to do standing when i was 16.
yeah so i went to battle just dealing
with my parents and you know the korean
church uh
culture i guess i would call it culture
and it's very toxic right because your
parents motives they move based on what
the community says about them i am a
reflection of my father right and if i
do bad things my father is reflected
poorly so i am not allowed to live yeah
lots of shame lots of peer pressure what
are the jones is doing the shame was the
biggest part right so if i went out and
that was the biggest issue my dad had
with me was that
because he was a pastor he was a deacon
if i didn't behave correctly he would
look as a as a terrible parent right
right but there came to a point in time
and the funny thing is like this was
advice that my mom was giving me she was
like after i die you are just left with
your choices so what do you want to do
but the hard part about she has to
support her husband right so she's like
she on the list you would be like just
get a college degree and then do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you know
yeah just get the degree just show them
that you did it and then just whatever
you could leave do whatever you want but
i couldn't even get to the point where i
wanted the college degree so there was a
moment where my father and i had this
thing where i remember i was just super
unhappy i could i was just trying to
balance what everybody else wanted out
of me and that that went from the the
the friends that i hung around with that
went from two career choices
uh the the women that i was dating
everything was just never what i wanted
to do wow and at a certain point you
just go i'm unhappy i am the most
unhappiest person ever and if you're
young out there i'm pretty sure you've
had these moments too where uh i guess
it was like depression where you woke up
and you go why am i even awake i'm gonna
do the same [ __ ] every day that i hate
yeah so when you have that moment that
that's the rock bottom and then after
that i'm like okay i want to do things
that i want to do and i want to behave
the way that i would be proud of so i i
had a moment before i had that moment i
gave up and i told my dad and i remember
this moment too i was at the house i was
literally korean style like on my knees
like father you know doing that [ __ ] i
was like i will do whatever you ask me
was it level-headed was it like
a conversation that escalated into an
argument that got there or was it
something that was like premeditated
like i'm gonna ask my dad and we're both
calm hey can i talk to you
it was never that it was it's korean
fireworks dude like just always yelling
so it's already a fight that escalated
into in the korean household that i that
i grew up in it was either there was
there was zero to ten thousand that's it
hey are you hungry do you want something
to eat and the other part was did you
kill yourself it you piece of [ __ ] good
morning
i remember it just kind of built up
because he was already super
disappointed in my life choices or
whatever right at 16 bro dude super
young man but um this one wasn't 16 this
was when i was uh
right after i came back from riverside
so i was what uh 1920. and so i was like
okay and he was just disappointed
because i you know i was moping around
or whatever which albeit like his
intentions are great but just like most
people who haven't had the emotional
tools that weren't given to them by
their parents he doesn't know how to
communicate this i don't know this at
this age so we were just screaming and
yelling at each other and then i was
bawling and crying and i just told them
you know what since you have the key to
life since you know exactly you're
[ __ ] miss cleo you tell me what to do
you talk to your dad like i was like you
tell me what to do i'll do exactly what
you tell me to do to the [ __ ] tea and
if you can guarantee that i'll be happy
i'll do it and he goes cool my dad i've
never seen a guy so happy in his life he
goes oh it's my time you know
let me get the book i wrote yeah
it's a scroll
right removes his sleeve the [ __ ]
thing no but he um tells me what to do
which is go to school get good grades i
aced all my classes miserable as [ __ ] so
getting that a the straight a's right
never made me feel good i'm like this is
useless i've done everything that you
asked me you said i'd be happy and i'm
not yeah happy so at that point i was
like i'm pretty much done with this but
now i have to figure out what what i
want to do so
you know i was i was doing stand up at
16 and i was still continuing doing it
on the side so i had to figure out if
i'm going to leave college or not or
whatever
don't know yet so at this point
and quickly after this we had another
fight i left my dad parents house i
hadn't talked to him for a whole year so
during this time i was
just move out i moved out my cousin took
me in so i went to his house which is
like 30 or 40 minutes out from where i
was living already so i live with my
cousin he took me in i paid him a
minimum amount of rent i was working at
the men's warehouse i and the funny
thing is that my parents still needed
help at the business so whenever my dad
had to leave somewhere for uh to do
stuff outside the store i came in and i
i just told him before you come back to
the store you call our mom i don't want
to see your face wow so i'll come in and
i'll leave after
so
i kept in contact with my mom yeah
and then lo and behold after that you
know the youtube kind of came around the
corner so i had a point too where i was
like okay
i'm doing too much now i'm trying to
help my parents out with this business
uh
i'm doing uh what's it called trying to
help my parents with my business i'm
working on men's warehouse school all
these other part-time jobs whatever
something has to go yeah right and like
this is small detail we actually
reconciled in between this time so oh
good yeah there's a long story behind
that it'll take hours to talk about that
but we reconciled yeah we don't want to
hear it yeah no [ __ ] because you'd be
bawling and crying with this
but we uh figured out what we wanted to
do i didn't figure out what i wanted so
my father took me back in we were good
but i still was unhappy because i was
doing too much so i said i have to give
up something what do i have to give up
i couldn't give up school so i stopped
doing stand-up i stopped doing music i
stopped doing all the other stuff that
made me happy and i went back to just
doing school because i wanted to finish
finish up i uh then get my degree yeah
make your dad happy do what your mom
said exactly so do that on the download
youtube happened
i figured out that oh if i'm not going
to do stand-up i could just make these
funny videos and then kind of see what
happens after that and that's when the
video blew up so i went back i remember
i had a blue book test i forgot for what
course it was
sat down i was like i can't do this i
took my marker wrote a big old smiley
face in it i closed it i turned it in
and i walked up and i left and i dropped
out of college
yeah went back home that day i looked at
my dad and i was like hey i'm done with
college i'm not doing this anymore whoa
and he knew that video was going crazy
what did your dad say when that happened
he hated it he hated it he didn't
understand it he was like you're so
close like you have
at that point i had so many credits you
guys are like pie fingers to the page no
he wasn't gonna so the reason why he
would he never hit me at that point
anymore because the reason why they
talked 20 years because he hit me and i
was like you can no longer put your
hands on me anymore i'm done with this
yeah and so uh he was just like you know
obviously angry very upset
but then my mom just my mom was my hero
so she took him aside and said listen
he's old what do you want from him like
he can't be the person that you want him
to be you just have to let him live his
own life and so at that point he kind of
gave up on his dream of trying to mold
my life
and eve
he's still a really good father because
even if he didn't
agree with my choices at this point
whatever my mom said to him before i
left he bought me my imac so i could
edit
the imac that's in the background of all
of your earlier videos yeah that's the
that's the thing
he was never somebody too that said i
love you or whatever but he did it
through his actions and he always had a
good heart this is what he always
his intentions were always good is i
want my kids to be very successful i
want them to never have to struggle the
way that i did yeah but the problem with
that with the i think a lot of asian
parents they kind of cuddle their kids
too much to the point where they become
debilitated they don't know how to make
choices for themselves and when they're
out in the world when mommy and daddy
aren't there they go who's going to tell
me what to do yep and they freak out
they get these anxiety attacks i hated
that [ __ ] and i had to deal with that a
lot because my dad kept on whenever i
would try to do something for myself he
would get upset that i wasn't doing it
the way that he wanted to do it so he
would just do it for me so what happens
with that is that you become a useless
human being yeah because now oh you're a
robot just taking orders exactly so it
was just this weird relationship that we
had dad is always trying to do the best
for his kid and my mom said it the best
like you should feel that sorry for your
dad because he wants to develop this
strong relationship with you and your
brother but he does everything he can to
destroy your guys's relationship but he
doesn't know so you should feel sorry
for him he wants to be close he doesn't
have the tools what a good mom yeah well
she i'm so weird because she went in
between that to try to jump out of her
car on the freeway so this is
kind of weird you know it sounds like
she's a good translator for your dad
though like your dad would just say
crazy [ __ ] that's my uh like i mean your
mom's translating it and make it more
palatable and okay i understand my dad's
good intentions yeah and that's my dad's
best friend so she knows how to
communicate his stupidity and bring it
down to earth but after a while
sometimes she's like i'm out of here
yeah i'm gonna kill myself
you want the dinner
there's a video too i have my mom
hitting herself in the head with like a
foldable chair
i'm crazy dude like something about
the they were arguing with my dad and
she he couldn't understand what she was
saying and they were fighting she goes
you don't understand what i'm saying she
starts hitting herself in the head and
my dad sends it to me he goes
i gotta divorce this lady and i'm like
no you're not bro
that's your life choice yeah no one else
wants is there any relapse because i
know it's really
like you know when you take your first
big move and you're gonna be
unapologetically you're like this is me
i'm gonna do this
but
sometimes you still experience guilt you
know like as like as you see success
you're like [ __ ] but this isn't what my
dad wants like did you ever have a
inclination to go man maybe i should go
back to school or i should go back and
make i don't know my homies happy my
brother happy or was it just as soon as
that clicked it was just i'm just gonna
do what what's right for me oh it's
clicking done i never look back after
that i can't look back there's no point
what's the point once you once you're
[ __ ] that many steps in going
backwards is just too much work yeah
you're here may live with your choices i
always have to live with my choices even
when i mess up and i mess up all the
times it's like a skill dude it's kind
of crazy how good i am at it you know
yeah like you when i make these mistakes
i just have to live with the choices i
can't be like oh if i would have done
this it would have been so much better
and you know
it's minus crypto but like other than
that
when we make these choices you have to
just commit to it and you have to accept
what comes with it because if you don't
you're you're you're an idiot like what
are you going to do you just you're
going to sit there and just wallow in
this in this filth all day like oh if i
would have done this then oh maybe i
should have done that there's absolutely
no point one thing you'll never get back
is time i don't ever want to die and
then or i'll be on the on my deathbed i
said i wish i would have done something
when i could have
this podcast is brought to you by sky
light frames
so if you're like me
then you live out of state and sometimes
it's hard to stay connected with your
family your mom your dad your grandma
your grandpa and your loved ones and
that's why i love skylight frames so
much because it's a touch screen photo
frame that you can email photos to and
they appear in seconds so my dad has one
set up in his kitchen and he could be
cooking and just hanging out and taika
could be doing something super cute and
i could take a picture of it email it to
him and he gets it on his screen
immediately and he gets to enjoy that
picture or me gio taika have a really
really cute moment and i just love that
picture i send that to him too it'll
appear on his skylight frame so that my
favorite picture now becomes his
favorite picture and it's effortless to
use the setup takes less than 60 seconds
and even the least tech savvy person can
use it believe me my dad still has a
flip phone to this day because he
doesn't want to deal with no touch
screen anything and he is able to set
this up and they also have a 100
satisfaction guarantee which is crazy so
if you don't like your skylight they'll
offer you a full
refund okay and we love skylight frames
so much we're offering our listeners ten
dollars off your purchase of a skylight
frame when you go to skylightframe.com
and enter the code bill b-e-a-w that's
why you get 10 off your purchase of a
skylight frame just go to
skylightframe.com enter the code bail b
e a w and that's sky light frame s-k-y
l-i-g-h-g f-r-a-m-e dot com use the code
bail this podcast is brought to you by
and you guessed it
me and gio's favorite game
best fiends in my opinion this is the
best match 3 style game out there
everyone else is pretty much just a copy
what i like about best fiends is that
you get to play through an actual
storyline meaning there's gonna be good
guys the fiends and also the bad guys
the slugs and you can start off as these
really cute baby versions of themselves
that's what the fiends are and they go
and they go beat up and they fight these
bad guys aka which are the slugs and all
the puzzles get increasingly more
challenging as you play and it's an
action-packed adventure and it's a
brain-boosting puzzle game all rolled
into one sometimes i'm just chilling at
the airport and i have nothing to do i
bust it out because you don't even need
wi-fi then you can just play and it's so
fun and it's really easy to pass the
time i'm not as good as geo so i'm only
on level 130 but i'm still playing and
it's super duper fun so if you want to
play and have fun and you just want to
just chill or hang out with your friends
download best fiends for free today at
the app store or google play that's
friends without the r best fiends where
does that come from for you that mindset
of like or like when did that concept
click of like time is limited you're
gonna be gone make this time here last
now it was when i was waking up and i
just didn't want to do anything and this
is at 16 or in your 20s this was like in
my 20s i would just wake up i would go
to work go to school and i just didn't
want to wake up i don't ever want to
feel that again i want to wake up and
and do the things that i want i want to
be very happy and i we all have that
ability and choice right and i think
that a lot of the times too personal
responsibility is something that this
generation just
in our generation too people just hate
that because it's easier just to put it
on somebody else and we're not saying
that there aren't reasons as to why
you're sad or why you're put into these
positions but when you take personal
responsibility it also helps you kind of
control the chaos yeah because if
everything is because of everybody else
you're going to live in chaos 24 7 and
it's exhausting yeah but if you could
say to yourself this bad should happen
what can i do to make it better so it
doesn't happen again you kind of take
control of this part that just makes
your life suck yeah you know it's not
easy it's [ __ ] hard and sometimes too
you do want to blame people all the time
but i've never met somebody who sat
around blaming everybody else for their
misfortunes that went anywhere
successful in their life not a single
person you tell me you you let me meet
that person and i'll and i'll [ __ ]
dedicate my life to living their life
then but we gotta we gotta find that
person let me find that person
impossible though it's impossible
because the game of life that you're
playing
it's like if you feel like the
controller is always in other people's
laps you're never going to play the game
that you want you got to take the
control and go up and down and do all
the things you need to do yeah and i
feel bad too for a younger generation
now because now your success is always
based on what you see somebody else does
on social media right and success is
such a relative it's so relative
what do you what do you mean by success
yeah because i see people that i've
known for years who are friends and they
don't
they don't have like the riches or
whatever but they're the happiest people
on earth like who's to say that they're
not successful in what what sense are
they not successful 100 and when you see
like these these videos these pictures
that are in your face that says you know
i'm living the best life that i can you
don't know what's going on in their
personal life those people show you what
they want to show you 24 7. even us we
know people who are so [ __ ] good at
that but we know what's going on in
their lives and it's a facade and you
know people have to do what they have to
do you guys have brand deals or whatever
you have to show this this great great
life so you can make sure that you have
to pay your bills that's perfectly fine
but it's up to you guys as a viewers to
understand that your life is not
supposed to be based on this false idea
of what happiness is whatever makes you
happy you figure that out we can't
figure that out for you
like like the way dan bilzerian lives
everybody looks at that and says oh i
want that are you sure
you sure about that you know how many
tampons he has to have
inventory like stand by
dude man and these [ __ ] keep flushing
them down the toilet clobbed up in his
gold toilets she sucks bro you think you
want unlimited [ __ ] bro that's just
rough man really really really there's
no space in the bed you roll over
there's a chick over here there's
another hot ass chick over here trying
to stretch out your arms just [ __ ]
titties right there
damn it man
it's hard living like that you won't be
damn busy you want the bets yourself
yeah man nice and cool you know so is
this mindset something that was applied
or something that you picked up uh
when so i'm just gonna assume it comes
from the parents right because i'm
always like who do you spend the most of
your life with in the beginning of your
life and it's your family right it's
definitely my mom i think my mom's my
biggest influence when i kind of look
back at it and she's definitely one of
the bigger ones like in what way but
she's always happy has she always been
unapologetically her like i'm going to
do because this is what i want to a
fault bro
this one could definitely reflect on
some of her actions you know
some crazy stuff but she's always been
about like
here's one of the things too like she as
long as i've known her how poor we grew
up how little money that we had she has
never ever said i hate my life and she
has never said i hate my job
two things she's never ever said that's
[ __ ] badass do you what i'm saying so
stop that you observe that
yeah also she told me
bone in her body dude
she was like whenever you ever see me
complain about our job she goes i'm
happy so you know
why are you why do you complain so much
that's why i don't like people who
complain i like it if you complain you
make jokes about and you're allowed to
grieve and feel the sorrow that you have
but if you're sitting here and waiting
for a pity party every day i i don't
want to [ __ ] hear it it's i not
because i'm not empathetic to your pain
not because i don't care about you if
you're in my personal circle but if
you're sitting here just for me to
absorb your negative emotions just
because you want to let it out and i
have to take it i don't want to sit
around for that because at the end of
the day and everybody knows this you are
the closest people to your circle the
closest people that you relate to are
the people that you're going to be no
matter how strong of an individual you
are if i hung around pieces of [ __ ]
which i never talked to when i don't
hang out with this guy
you love me elevate my life dude
it's it's hard and you know we always
think that we could be better and we
were talking about it too how sometimes
where when we hang around people who are
a reflection of our past life it gives
us ptsd yeah it scares us a little bit
makes us feel uncomfortable and i don't
know what it is and um recently too i
was hanging around a bunch of you know
thuggish-like people and i started
emulating their behavior as if this is
who i am like yeah you know how [ __ ]
yeah good you know and i'm really
uncomfortable yeah and i wanted to leave
that situation so bad so imagine if i
was around these people 24 7 i would
imitate that lifestyle and i don't want
to do it so who you are
really influences who are you around
really influences who you are and my mom
was literally that person in my corner
hey do what your dad tells you but you
pursue what makes you happy even when it
came to somebody i married she said that
if you when you marry somebody
you are going to be stuck with that
person your father me i'm going to be
dead you're going to be with your wife
and your kids so make the right choices
when you decide to be with this person
you have to live with your choices so
that's how you have to live your life
that's what my mom has always told me
you live with your choices you deal with
what you make deal with the bid that you
make and so i've always been living my
life that way since she said she told me
that because it was like one of those
woe moments it is i thought that she
wanted me to marry somebody that she
wanted me to marry wow but she was like
no
you just have to marry somebody that you
know that you're going to be happy with
because if not
i could hate that woman but if she makes
you happy i'm not married to her you're
going to have kids with her she's gonna
raise your kids she's gonna build the
house the household vibe with you so i
was like oh okay i'm gonna take what
this woman says and apply it to my life
and i just and i have to remind myself
of that all the time that's dope when
they talk to you as an adult you're like
oh [ __ ] thanks i feel like an adult and
i can make adult decisions now
especially when they give you the like
the responsibility switch where you get
to go well if i do this i have to accept
the consequences versus a lot of times i
think the parents they create try to try
to create such a controlled and
sheltered environment yeah where the
responsibility is still technically on
the parent so the kid feels like i'm not
really driving this car nor am i
responsible for the consequences and
they just never learn yeah but then with
you they're like you have to live with
your choices and go ahead and make that
choice i mean they've tried to control
me since i was a little kid and it was
[ __ ] damn near impossible so i'm
pretty sure they're just exhausted too
like even my dad there's moments where
sometimes we're about to get into a
heated argument he just goes
[Music]
he already knows where it's gonna go
yeah he's [ __ ] strong-willed
[ __ ] yeah there's it's just
pointless too his his goal to now he he
the last fight that we had was like five
six years ago nice and so it's been so
long since we had a fight and we even uh
the last thing that he said to he goes i
only have a few years left on this earth
i don't want to do a fight so
we're not fighting anymore you live the
way you want to live i live the way i
want to live and we'll just be
respectful towards each other that's
beautiful and so we're like cool and i
was like all right just one more thing
last week
out of all the things that you've done
whether it's in front of the camera
behind the camera in your personal life
or career
what's the thing you're the most proud
of like you're like man when i die like
when i die i close my eyes i'm in that
casket pretending that i'm dead
eating a last piece of donut
what are you like man i can take this to
heaven i feel real good because i did
this
you've had movies music netflix
uh
you're you're just your fan success
all of that that's hard floating man
because i haven't died yet
so who knows but so far
up until this point if if right now the
switch is flipped your life source is
gone
you're on the way to heaven and in that
moment you're reflecting back on this
whole time that you've been up until now
and you're like damn i'm really proud of
this point this moment in my life i
think it's just
the way that i've carried myself
throughout my cur entertainment in
my career entertainment my entertainment
and careers my career's entertainment
okay so english
english isn't one of the things yeah
english is so hard
you're the most proud of right now is
how you've carried yourself in your
career as an entertainer like that's my
biggest thing because it makes me
i i have nobody has ever been able to
push me in a way that i felt that i was
doing something that i didn't want to do
beautiful so everything that i've done
whether it was successful or not i
wanted to do it and that's all that
really matters right
and
that's the part that i'm happy about the
most like i've
there are so many things that people
have told me that i should have done
that wouldn't have happened if i didn't
do it that way and i proved them wrong
right you said oh you're not going into
acting classes you didn't sign up for
leslie khan's like [ __ ] all this
other [ __ ] like how do you expect to get
into like these films and sundance cool
i did it so what about you you've been
acting for 10 years where's your
sundance film suck my big korean balls
suck my [ __ ] i'm glad you didn't say
dick because i would have definitely
stepped in and i'm like that's not what
i heard you have not seen it it's a
little cold right now
if i warmed it up average and so
yeah but like that's the type of stuff
that i dislike people always like to
make you feel small so they can feel
great about their life choices they go i
didn't do it that way so you can't do it
that way [ __ ] you
how about that you know i'll do it the
way that i want to do it and then we'll
see what happens it's like oh and like
for example too i mean this is a very
bad habit that i don't suggest people
have it's like doing stuff out of
revenge and just like puree it drives
people though
100
man yeah so it's it's like you're either
motivated by me i mean it's passion even
like passion is hate hatred even like
motivation
it's all about [ __ ] those
[ __ ] that doubted them from
before yeah yeah and that's like the
biggest trend
[ __ ] myself yeah
that's the biggest motivator so you're
you're the norm dude
it's weird though because i always
advise against it too because once you
reach you you kill this imaginary enemy
you're you're what are you left with
yeah yeah yeah
oh okay that's not true fulfillment it's
not truthful because you didn't do it
for yourself you did be for somebody
else and that's like the the sundance
thing was kind of that too it's like i
uh i thought that i mean i'm still
acting till this day but the reason why
i act is different now is only just to
create the stories that i want to create
and that's it it doesn't have to be on a
big screen it could go on youtube and
i'm happy with it yeah as long as
somebody saw it i'm perfectly okay
because at the end of the day i made a
sundance film yeah
and i did really well so you can't tell
me i can't do what you do can you do
what i do i don't think so i don't think
you could go out there and say what you
really feel and back it up with your
actions i don't think any of you [ __ ]
can do that give me a second
and i only say that because i've met
people like this yeah where they come up
and we had a conversation about this too
we we brown-nosed with some of these
like hollywood celebrities and they're
perfectly awesome people too
but when they come up to me and they say
i wish i could say what you say and but
i can't because you know i got to keep
up with the joneses well cool that's you
that's not me so you can't live my life
you can't because you can't deal with
the consequences you can't deal with the
fact that when you say something you
have to say i'm sorry i [ __ ] up none
of you could do that and i don't know
why i don't understand yeah
they feel like they have to say
everything that's perfect and you don't
you could say what you want and
be convicted and feel like it's right in
the moment but when you feel wrong you
could be like oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] up a
little bit my bad and i don't have to
and by the way you'll never have twitter
will never make me apologize i have to
feel it yeah so if i feel like i make
these mistakes that i have to say then a
lot of like people in the entertainment
world can't live like that because
they're afraid about their paycheck well
don't don't live your life by the dollar
sign live but live your life by what
makes you happy and do it respectfully
too by the way i don't like going out
here just bashing human beings 24 7.
yeah but if i feel a certain way i
always do it in a respectful manner and
i you know adjust accordingly but even
then people can't do that i just don't
understand how people can live like that
yeah like it's hard it's too hard i've
never done anything that you regretted
we got him thinking
where you're like [ __ ] but then maybe
later on you're like oh man i'm so glad
i did that anyways because it became a
part of who i am definitely like things
i've said to my dad like those are the
things that i regret because he's i said
things out of anger because i wasn't uh
an adult because i was a child and i
never understood what he was going
through exactly you don't care when
you're when you're hurting when you're
personally hurt you want everybody to
feel the pain that you're going through
and that's the only way that you feel
vindicated and justified so that idea of
empathy when you're so heated and you're
young it's hard to think about what
somebody else goes through
especially i think because like asian
american kids deal with this the most
because they don't understand they they
almost want their parents to deal with
their love and affection and the the
nuclear american family in the way that
they want to but they don't understand
that their parents are brand new
americans they came into this country
with their cultures and ideals intact
you grew up in this country
molded by this country's ideals and
you're asking this person who grew up 30
40 years somewhere else to adapt to what
you believe but you will never do it for
they're incapable of it yeah i've
understood that now yeah they could only
do it the way that they can and so
there's a there's a there's a give and
take and i think a lot of asian kids
don't understand it's like how come you
can't do what i ask of you well how come
you can't do what they ask of you then
yeah you have to be in the middle
somehow yeah and i never did that that's
probably one of the things i say i i
regret but i definitely learn from those
mistakes but that only comes with time
yeah there's like telling their parents
like
mom my love language is words of
affirmation and they're like i don't
even know what that means yeah
dude there are people that i know like
korean friends that i know like they
told their parents like you're hurting
my feelings and they go what's appealing
yeah like i don't know what's appealing
what's the peeling is a pork in a stove
this is what i peel right now
banana i peel you know like they don't
understand what this [ __ ] is where were
your friends going like and they didn't
[ __ ] want to talk about my feelings
yeah no they were and i just and this is
i'm talking about people that i know
that are at the time they were in their
late 20s and i was like you still don't
get it yeah that's too old man
how do you not get it like they your
parents never had the words i love you
they never had the words of like oh what
are you going through are you okay they
never were given these tools and now
you're expecting them to understand this
foreign language without giving them the
right course or the or or the patience
or the grace yeah so it's like we can't
ask our parents to give us something
that we haven't given them either yeah
so when i hug my dad now and he hugs
back he hugs back i don't know it's like
oh it's like hover hands
but he didn't do that before exactly so
in my mind i know the hover hand is
literally him picking me off my feet
spinning around 360 and then [ __ ]
kissing me like
i know that's his version of it that's
all he can do yeah cause that's all he
can do and i'm like
from him going to like being proud of me
and then like punching me in the arm to
being able to do a hover hand i'm like
that's his best and he's trying his face
i've met his dad so many times
and the only thing he's ever said to me
is
like no those aren't even words bro
he can't speak english
and
this podcast is sponsored by better help
that's better h-e-l-p
is there something that's interfering
with your happiness or is preventing you
from achieving your goals you know
sometimes
a
incident can happen where it kind of
gets your mind going or something bad
happen and you're like you don't know
how to digest it or even a memory from
the past can come back and kind of
trigger something and you're like oh man
i'm not in the best state of mind and
what i like about betterhelp is that
they can assess your needs and match you
with their own licensed professional
therapist and if you start communicating
in under 48 hours it's not a crisis
hotline it's not self-help it is
professional
therapy done securely online and many
times you know we need a third unbiased
opinion to help us sort out our thoughts
a little bit and we have friends we
could have family we have our
significant others but many times they
can give you a biased opinion or bias
thought especially if they're involved
or have been around what you're dealing
with so this is why i like therapy this
is why i think it's super important to
work with a professional and this
surface is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
at any time and send a message to your
therapist and you'll get timely
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone session
so you don't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as
traditional therapy which is super
awesome so if you want to start living a
happier life today go visit their
website you can read their testimonials
that are posted daily okay go visit
betterhelp.com
bail b-e-a-w that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over two million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of a experienced
professional so many people have been
using better health that they're
actually recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states okay so
here's a special offer you get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com bill
that's betterhelp.com bill b-e-a-w
dude i had [ __ ] dinner with my dad
last week
and i was supposed to eat at i think
seven
i show up at 705 because running a
little bit late from the barber i go in
the parking lot and my dad's like in the
parking lot wondering where the [ __ ] i
was like he's been waiting for me for an
hour
and i'm like dude i'm only like five
minutes late i'm like i go like this so
my dad goes inside he's even away from
the other car and walk both of us walk
inside he walks inside by himself when i
go inside
and i sit down at his booth his food has
already been finished he's like where
the [ __ ] have you been and i'm like it's
705. because i've been here since 6 30
and i'm like
i thought you said what i'm meaning at
seven he goes i am but i was hungry so
that's the type of that person that my
dad is it's just everything is i had it
has to happen now and when i'm done i'm
just gonna take off so he's so like
literally he was done with his food and
he was like i'm gonna leave but then he
got up and he sat back down he goes
actually i think i'm supposed to have a
conversation with myself oh that's what
he said no no i could see his brain like
his this gear's turning he's like
[ __ ] yeah there's smoke coming out of
his ears i can see his functions the
hearts and the love like growing you
know and so like he was sitting there he
was eating he's waiting for me and then
he can tell that like my my water was
going down so he would call the waiter
like just a lot more nurturing things
that i was like oh [ __ ] i've never seen
it before funniest thing about the story
is it's just basic human thesis
if you saw me he said hello
what is basic human decency for whom i
know that's what i'm saying it's just so
funny like you're dead i mean
i don't know if you've ever told the
story about your dad's past and how he
got here it's so
crazy dude yeah so understanding what he
had to get what he went through yeah see
how he is as a human being now is
actually leaps and bounds better but
it's just so funny that it's just
i should sit here
he's all sweating and [ __ ] trying to
fight himself
can he get some water
like just dying on the inside yeah
that's amazing okay so that's one of the
things that you say that you've
regretted the most yeah um have you like
fixed all of that have you gone back and
repaired all that you apologize or have
a conversation about every one of those
things that you said that you're like
[ __ ] that i hurt my dad's feelings
no we kind of just squashed it and
squashed it when we had our last fight
we're just like oh we understand each
other now
we're good because we uh the the exact
thing that i told them i can't remember
what it is now i said it on a podcast so
i i remembered it when it was fresh
um don't plug the podcast uh i the
genius brain podcast
[ __ ]
but um so this was recent
yeah it wasn't it was a few years ago oh
okay so but it was it's pretty recent
though because what pandemic was two
years now yeah yeah yeah so we
definitely squashed it where i
understood where he was coming from
because he explained how his parents
were and i was like i never had this you
can't expect me to change yeah and he
was like the biggest difference between
me and you is that you think you're so
much better than me but the reason why
i'm better than you now is because i
knew that i had bad qualities that i got
from my parents and i never thought i
was better than my father i was like
this is trying to [ __ ] give me some
wisdom so
that's when i was like oh maybe i am a
little harsh like maybe i don't see
i don't see that he's trying and he's
tried like did he say that part again
that [ __ ] was deep say it again i just
roll it back i forgot what i said
about his dad like that that he saw the
same flaws in his own father from
himself
um but he never thought he was better
than his father yeah so like those are
the type of things where it's like oh
i'm still very immature like i don't
give my father the same amount of
empathy and grace that i'm asking from
yeah and did you say like but you can't
see that because you never had a million
subscribers
i was like yeah but dad i actually have
friends
burned [ __ ]
but yeah
we got to know each other a little bit
better at that point i'm like he just
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's doing
you know like one of the funniest things
that he ever said to us
i said to him i'm not sure if it was
this time or was the time before but i
said
when have you ever looked at me and told
me i did a good job whenever you ever
said those words you did a good job he
goes i tell you all the time i'm like
when yesterday i went to your butt and i
went
i was like what that's your good job and
but that is his good job
you know
and i'm like okay
how am i supposed to know this though
you don't tell me these things and
that's why i have to talk to my mom so
she could translate his stupidity over
to me and then i'm like oh i understand
what he's doing now so and you know like
joe he came over on a weekend and he saw
my dad he's like oh your dad doesn't
really talk or interm interact much i
was like he's just happy that his son's
home
and he's happy that you know joe's here
or whatever so he's just he's gonna go
out get food and drinks and whatever and
this is how he's communicating his love
language
yeah hey what do you need today oh
before you take the car he starts
washing the car so it's clean before i
take it off that's cute yeah so he
starts doing these type of things and i
go oh
he loves me it's not the way that it's
not the the you know seventh heaven yeah
hey you know what are you doing how are
you feeling you're feeling sad
you know he's never going to do that
he'll just do things the way that he
knows how right tell my mom to stay cook
some stuff they're hungry you know and
then my mom start cooking she sees me
eat it and the kitchen [ __ ] yeah and
then my mom's super happy that she sees
me enjoying her food and i'm like oh
this is this is the stuff that's
important it's like they need to feel
that they're wanted and still needed
yeah so i will eat their food i will ask
my dad hey i need help with this i don't
technically need it i can find somebody
else who could do it but if it makes my
father happy i'm going to ask him first
because he feels important and needed in
my life so yeah though you know those
are the pub
that's why i regret the way that i
behaved earlier because if i would have
done this a little earlier the
relationship might have been better yeah
i wasted a lot of time but once again
i was young yeah i i wouldn't have been
able to do that when i was 16. it was
impossible but now
that i'm older i'm able to just kind of
make up for time that has been lost and
it feels good
hell yeah and then like i mean i don't
know what your plans are with starting a
family and stuff but i mean we've had
our talks where you're just like yeah at
one point i would want to have kids and
[ __ ] and it's dope to have a healthy
relationship now with your parents
because i mean they're gonna be teaching
your future kids like life lessons you
know and if you guys have like a
turbulent relationship then they might
not be around very much because you
[ __ ] hate each other your family is
like super important and i'm not sure
that's what people really think about
when you're younger because you're just
thinking about getting your dick wet
yeah yeah or i couldn't wait to get my
dick wet yeah what's the version of
dickwood for girls
[ __ ]
okay
so you know you just be stuffed yeah
you know stuff the stalking well no for
women it's more like just having a
relationship oh yeah
finding the love of your life yeah
you're trying to get that dick wet you
know and you're not thinking about what
are the key components in having a
strong family and it goes beyond just
the person that's right in front of you
like how is their relationship with
their family if they're still around you
know
do they have battle scars and from years
of just like
trauma are you are you capable of
dealing with that and if you are then
that's great if not then you have to
recognize that really early on and my
dad used to tell me this when i was
younger too but i was just like man you
don't even you just be judging people
bro like i used to tell him like he goes
he would always say like what's their
family life like i was like why does it
matter if i love them he goes wow he's
like he's like no he goes like you have
to look at their family life you these
are things you have to think about but i
didn't hear it like that i heard i'm
like you trying to stop me from loving
bro
but now i get what he's saying because
now i have been with women who haven't
dealt with their issues with their
family stuff that's happened in their
past they're not open to communicating
it with me or a therapist yeah and just
we never could connect because
they were in a state where they were
just [ __ ] up from all this past [ __ ]
up [ __ ] that's happened to them i
couldn't help them they didn't want to
reconcile their stuff with their family
members and it just affected our whole
lives and our relationships dissipated
because of that so
i just never thought about that when i
was younger and it's super important
right yeah there's a lot of things you
don't really think about when you're
younger like before you just think of oh
it's just me versus my pops and if it
doesn't work out [ __ ] it i don't need to
talk to him but then as i got older and
even as much trauma as i have between me
and my dad and me and my mom the older i
get i'm like i don't want taika to be
grandma-less or grandpalace so it's like
for me
even if not for myself i want to make
sure that i have a good relationship
with my parents just for taika so like
my mom come around my dad come around so
recently i've been making like a huge
effort to really fix those things like
even with jio's help like my mom would
send me all these like whack ass
pictures of her in the mountains and
stuff
[ __ ] worse and like before like
sometimes i just won't even answer
somebody this is so [ __ ] boring you
can't even take pictures right and uh
how many mountains do you have to take
pictures at and uh but you look like nah
you gotta like you gotta understand it's
their love language you know that's
something i'm constantly practicing so
now i so that so silence turned into oh
that looks nice to how does that make
you feel what do you like about these
mountains and now we're having more of a
conversation and i'm like holy [ __ ] like
i feel like we're actually healing
uh the trauma that we had in the past i
still think there's a lot of things we
need to talk about so that we're on the
same page because i'm sure i was
probably like a nightmare of a son to
her and absolutely she was a nightmare
for mom to me but to me like when i look
at taika i almost feel like that
resolution is even that important right
what's important to me is as soon as
this pandemic [ __ ] is over people can
travel that grandma can see grandson
grandson can see grandma and that's all
i really care about yeah yeah yeah 100
this is also too it's like you start
living for your kids instead of your own
personal wants and needs yeah and then
you could start healing by watching the
relationship that your
your you know kid will have with grandma
and grandpa and you know it's different
too like what your parents were going
through at that time when they were
raising you is different from what
they're going through now yeah they're
allowed to feel a little more they're
allowed to to see these things that they
even have time to feel more exactly
because they're so [ __ ] busy yeah
before my dad didn't have time to
[ __ ] feel the only thing he wanted to
feel is his knuckles on the back side of
my head
that's really about it me too i mean me
and your dad can connect quite a bit you
ain't never put your hands on me dude
and if you do you know okay that's
different though
that's a big difference
um okay kind of moving moving
away a little bit from that topic of
family let's say that
um
everything were to disappear right the
world ends you're the only person that's
killing myself or not the world okay no
the world doesn't end then uh but
you somehow get amnesia everything that
you know
that you've owned is gone however the
skills and all the life lessons that uh
you have attained through all your 46
years of existence
um you still have those so you could
sing you can act or do stand-up comments
you have the wisdom you can still eat uh
two people's amount
so you still possess all of this okay
yeah but again you don't remember your
old life you don't know like
it's kind of like a clean slate with the
wisdom and skills
what do you
what do you go into now what's the first
thing you would do or do you do the same
exactly the same thing really why not
life is good like what would i change
that's dope oh it doesn't have to change
anything like maybe maybe it could be
something where you're like [ __ ] man
maybe i wouldn't have stopped
uh stand up and i would have pursued
that way harder
i could give or take anything away from
my life i don't care you could take
anything away from me so even for you
like the biggest passion that you have
if you don't have it it's fine i'll find
something else that's dope everything is
temporary uh what's what's something
then that's super sacred to you is it
the family unit relationships that would
be the saddest part like you're losing
your the time and energy you spend on
cultivating amazing relationships that
is the part that's the hardest
everything else goes away that's my [ __ ]
every everything else goes
away like when people think that they
have their career figured out you have
your career figured out for now yes
your wants always change because some
people like time i'll die if i'm not a
graphic designer
but then guess what you're in a [ __ ]
car accident both of your hands are gone
now what yeah what do you do you just
did it but that's like the fun part
about life though you're not that's the
fun part about your life in a first
world country let me correct that when
you when you live in a world where you
have options the biggest thing that
we're burdened with now is choice true
what am i going to do that is a first
world [ __ ] problem not looking down
on you i i deal with that problem but
that problem is actually a blessing you
have the time to think about what you
want to do how [ __ ] amazing is that
[ __ ] yeah you get to pick and choose
your problems and you get the pivot you
get the pivot and figure something else
out and guess what if you don't like it
after six seven years guess what you
could try something else as long as you
can figure out a way to make your make
your ends meet and then you're pretty
much pretty you know you're good to go
and you have like the good support
around you and you have like these great
relationships that you've cultivated
then you're you're the geo like the
relationship you have with geo let me
ask you something no no this is my
podcast you can't ask me [ __ ] uh that
right there that mindset though so you
started and i know you were joking right
we [ __ ] around so much but we can get
really deep and and that's what i love
about just our dynamic um but when i was
talking about how you're kind of like
this modern day [ __ ] renaissance man
where you're doing anything and
everything in creative spaces and you're
like doing [ __ ] well and you're like
but that's so unstable
like i know you're kidding when you say
that kind of um but i think that mindset
is the mindset of a [ __ ] winner you
know i think that's the mindset of
someone that's never going to fail like
really fail and struggle i feel like
that's that's like at least for me i
feel like that's that's
the best mindset to have
[Laughter]
you know what
trials and tribulations build a strong
person and i woke up i was like what
happens if i don't have my meniscus this
day
oh [ __ ] i love it
one time apologetic
i ain't never sorry for nothing
no but that's one [ __ ] i [ __ ] i
that's why i [ __ ] with you so hard you
haven't died yet
because you have this strong will to
[ __ ] get it sometimes i feel like
god's out there he's just like [ __ ] he
lived
[Laughter]
i was like i just got him
no you have a dope [ __ ] mindset you
know what i mean like your mindset is
one that it's like there's a wall there
all right cool well then that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that wall let's go this way
you know that's a different path that's
why that's why i'm like i mean i have a
similar mindset to that where it's like
[ __ ] it i'm gonna try anything and
everything that i can and if it takes
off cool um i genuinely like genuinely
like doing these things so i'm just
gonna keep going forward not expecting
to get money because i'm not ever doing
anything for money um i'm doing it for
the sake of experience or connection or
just what i'm gonna learn from it and
then money and all that [ __ ] will come
and i'm not saying too if anybody's
going to go down this path of just like
pursuing this form of happiness
it's going to be hard guys
it's going to be [ __ ] hard you are
going to have these moments when you're
going down this path where you're going
to second-guess yourself you're going to
feel like is this the right choice
because no one has done it like you
you can't you can't talk to anyone
because it's like you're on your own
path and you just have to do it and you
have to be committed to the choice that
this is the bed that you made and now
you have to lie in it and that's the
only comfort that i have it's like like
when i started doing podcasting i lost
so many subscribers i lost
probably
close like 400 000 subscribers
i lost a lot and i just said
adios that's okay this is what i want to
do i can't
dictate my life based on what these
other people want me to do and people
who really supported me stuck around and
the podcast does well it's amazing so
i'm okay with that and it's it's weird
too when here's the oddest thing when
people say this to somebody they go oh
your numbers aren't that great you kind
of fell off
okay but based on who
yeah yeah based on who
i'm well enough known now that you wrote
on my channel so i'm clearly somebody to
you but at the end of the day it doesn't
really matter i could youtube could
disappear tomorrow the podcast could
disappear tomorrow i'll figure out a
different job and i'll still live my
life happy you can always be a clown i
could definitely do that i can start
potlocking in [ __ ] santa monica just
suck bye bye you know jesus christ
i'll figure it out you know yeah all
this stuff can disappear your careers
are your career and what you want is
always going to change and and i think
like once you become comfortable with
that you're comfortable with the chaos
the chaos becomes something you can
control so oh i want it to be a stand-up
comic maybe i don't like that so much
let's do youtube instead youtube's fun
oh youtube's getting a little exhausting
maybe i want to go into acting acting
has been fun i'll keep it on the back
button but let me try something else and
i'm not doing it half-assed either i'm
doing my research i'm i'm really dying
that's what i love about you too
everything you do whether it's from
cameras to fighting to anything that you
want like you dive deep into it and you
never half-ass anything that you do it
feels good to when you accomplish these
goals too like even like kickbox
kickboxing was [ __ ] hard for me like
people have to understand when i started
kickboxing i was 280 pounds it was hard
it was difficult and let me tell you
your boy
thought he had hands
isn't it always funny when you're doing
something and you think you're [ __ ]
kicking ass and you review the footage
and you're like oh i'm [ __ ] scared
that part was crazy i'm like dog
somebody hacked into my phone and slowed
the footage down
but in my mind i thought it was really
dope but those things are also humbling
experiences yeah and it was difficult
and like i said that's an example of me
saying like even if you want to pursue
these things there there's so much
trials and tribulations in order for you
to get to the place that you want to be
and you know it's been three years since
i started kicking well maybe two years
and years like one year i stopped but
i've gotten to a point where i'm
comfortable with it where i'm like oh
this is the level that i enjoy if i want
to become better at this i have to
forego other things in my life in order
for me to pursue kickboxing hell no you
know
and i'm happy with now i can move on to
something else whether it's jiu jitsu
it's boxing i don't know salsa i don't
give a [ __ ] what it is
i've seen those hips you should get into
this
i'll figure it out i don't know what
that next move is yet but i'm okay with
that and that's the exciting part of
life like you get to pick and choose
what you want to do and i think that
when you kind of commit yourself to one
thing you're also telling yourself that
this is what you're the only thing that
you're capable of and that's not true
you're capable of whatever the [ __ ] that
you want to do i'm not saying you're
gonna be good at it you you're probably
gonna be terrible at it but at least you
could try yeah i also like that your
gauge of happiness
has many metrics you know it's like it's
not all your eggs in one basket it's
almost like you know like an eq on like
a stereo it's like okay my relationship
my free time
my youtube career my martial arts it's
almost like you're a constant adjusting
to find the happiness so for you like
your happiness meter is dictated by so
many things when people like talk [ __ ]
or whatever like oh he lost followers
like yeah but i'm happy as [ __ ] yeah
like do you see all the free time i have
that the amazing relationships that i
have like you're just judging one thing
and you're just projecting yeah i fell
asleep on a swing the other day
she was amazing that [ __ ] was dying i
was gonna wear eight mosquito bites
but
but you know you know there's people out
there who's envious of that yeah but you
slept on a swing all day and named mario
mary'll just be looking at me at her
window and she's like doing her work
[ __ ] carpet tunnel what the [ __ ]
she's like she's like well what did you
do today you saw what i did
i was swagging baby
i was just chilling out there and it
feels good and that's a pretty [ __ ]
good life to me my parents were never
allowed to do that yeah they were
working at the store 80 hours a week my
father was in seminary school while i
was younger he was a full-time pastor
and he was running a business all the
time
it's hard life bro my dad would i didn't
have time if my dad maybe swung on a
swing as much as i did he probably
wouldn't beat my ass so much
you know yeah maybe i should have built
him a swing when we were younger yeah
you [ __ ] up yeah man i'm telling you i
have a lot of freedoms that i enjoy so
much and it's just it's great having
that perspective it's like my class will
always be half full it just always has
to be that way even when shit's tough
too like i've like you guys like we
talked about the bad luck that i have it
happens a lot to me it doesn't faze me
though it just is what it is like what
am i gonna do about it yeah i remember
one time so vanessa and i were uh
vanessa
you're all assistant my old assistant
uh my i just got this brand new tesla
and the semi truck hit me obliterated
the car right [ __ ] up oh i remember
that yeah i [ __ ] up my spy and
everything i was all [ __ ] up and [ __ ]
and i was just like all right whatever
four or five months uh pass i i get the
car back i'm she's in the car she's like
man it was a [ __ ] you didn't have your
car you had to pay for it and everything
else i'm like yeah it is what it is i'm
seeing my car
and this semi truck backs into my tesla
and wrecks it oh as i'm sitting in the
car and i'm like sitting there and i
just go
all right and i get outside and i go i
get this guy's information
i still have a picture of his license
this day he hasn't said hey zeus [ __ ]
you
it's a mexican dude this pool has a
glass eye he should not have a truck
license and somehow i'm the one person
on earth that got hit by a semi-truck
twice with a guy with a glass eye oh my
god
the same guy
and i just get up and i drive away i
said we'll figure it out but that's
looked at me she goes how do you do this
like i can't be you like there's so much
[ __ ] that [ __ ] happens to you how do you
deal with it why aren't you freaking out
i'm like why i can't i can't sit here
and cry all day it happened what am i
gonna do yeah we'll move on from this
i'm not gonna die i'm gonna still be
able to keep the lights on in my house i
still have fluid on my table we're good
yeah and at the end of the day it's
still a tesla
yeah some people don't even have a tesla
yeah simplify your life simplify what
makes you happy yeah glass half [ __ ]
love it i love it um
unfortunately it's the end of the show
it's the end of this episode
oh [ __ ]
um
it's the end of his knees
but no this is the reason why i wanted
to bring you on here because it's like
as much as i hate you i love you dude
and i love your mindset i love your
heart i love
the fact that relationships are the
biggest thing for you uh because i feel
like we all really need to focus on that
[ __ ] cause that's what makes the world
go round honestly
so [ __ ] i'm kind of sad to stop talking
now
now for the first time in your life
never never you know i don't like to
talk
but no david thank you so much for being
in our lives i [ __ ] love you i'm
inspired by you look at that smug ass
face
from my heart that i am so happy to have
you in my close circle i swear
i love you oh god this is so disgusting
bro
yeah yeah man thank you got these holes
in your pants thank you sir thank you i
appreciate you brother
anything you want to add no it was very
sweet i loved it i love the chemistry it
makes me feel happy right here it's my
guy right here
what do i want to do you might got too
dude okay hey you made it all right
thank you so much for listening and
we'll catch you next time